Another thing which has been bothering
me for some time is the fact that
fasting is one of the pillars of Islam.
Correct.
Now, but is there anything which uh
differentiates
the act of worship fasting the pillar
from the other four pillars? Perhaps
>> as I mentioned earlier that there are
five pillars of Islam and all of them
are important but the differentiation
between psalm
fasting as compared to other pillars is
that
the other pillars of Islam whether it be
salah whether it be zakat whether it be
hajj
it can be done by a person to show to
the others for yeah to be seen or to be
heard you know maybe I want to show
myself I'm a pass person so I'm offering
salah to show it to the people you know
I'm going for Hajj to make a show of it
can be possible can be possible I give
charity so that people will say I'm a
charitable person for sure but fasting
cannot be done for yah cannot be done to
show other people why a person can
easily fast and when no one is watching
he can have food he can have drink a
person who truly fast and abstains from
things that break the fast he's doing it
only for Allah and oneness so That is
the difference between
psalm and the other pillars of Islam.
And our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said it's mentioned in
say bkari volume number three in the
book of fasting had number 19 104 a
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said Allah says that all the
deeds done by the sons of Adam they are
for themselves only. He does it for
himself. But fasting is for me and I
will reward him.
And fasting is a shield.
A person fasting,
he abstains
from obscene things.
He abstains from lying
and abstains from yelling. And if a
person gets angry at him and abuses him,
he says, "I'm fasting. I'm fasting.
And then the hadith further goes on and
says that I swear by Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala in whose hand is the soul of
Muhammad
that the breath of a person who fasts is
sweeter to Allah than the scent of musk.
And a person who fast,
he
feels happy twice. once while breaking
the fast and once when he meets his
creator his lord. So in this hadith
there are various aspects mentioned.
First is that fasting is only done for
Allah subhanaa. No one else is. It's not
for secondly fasting is a shield. It's a
production.
It keeps you away from wrong things from
obscinity from vulgarity. And if someone
is angry it says that you have to calm
him down. Say I'm fasting. I'm fasting.
Because there's a hadith where Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam says in Sai
Bkari volume number three had number
2038 that the Satan runs in the
circulatory system of the human being
like the blood. So when we fast
we feel hungry when we hungry you know
the energy level goes down and the
things which required for doing things
away from Allah subhanaa tala. So tawa
level goes up because when we eat food
it goes into the blood. When we restrict
food, the restriction of the pathway of
the Satan is there. So that is the
reason when we fast, our taka level
increases.